Speaker 1: For those who are sick of hearing
about Donald Trump's campaign for 2020 for
his Republican nomination, today may be a
welcome change for you.
We are going to take a deeper dive into the
last 48 hours of the Ron DeSantis candidacy
for the 2024 Republican presidential nomination.
Now, one of the things that will not please
those who are sick of hearing about Trump
is that DeSantis is widely emulating Trump
so far in the early days of his campaign in
a number of different ways, including even
some of the insults that Trump became famous
for.
So Ron DeSantis spoke in Iowa yesterday, and
there are a number of different, disturbing
and comical realities.
First and foremost, we talked yesterday about
how Ron DeSantis said he would very much consider
pardoning Donald Trump if he were to become
president.
If you're running against Trump, you're not
going to win by saying, I'll pardon him because
the people who want Trump will vote for Trump,
and the people who are disgusted by Trump
aren't going to want to go with the guy that
says, I will pardon Trump, who you want to
get away from.
You're not going to beat Trump by avoiding
conflict and criticism the way that DeSantis
has done to a degree in the pre-campaign stages
of the last few months.
And you're certainly not going to defeat Trump
by using the same insults that some people
like.
In which case they'd vote for Trump and some
people don't like, in which case they're not
going to vote for the guy.
Copying the insults.
And Ron DeSantis yesterday during this speech
in Iowa.
Going with the Biden is in the basement thing,
which is a Trump thing.
This was Trump's line throughout the 2020
campaign.
Speaker 2: Our great American comeback starts
by sending Joe Biden back to his basement
in Delaware.
Speaker 1: Okay, you're not going to win this
way, Ron.
I mean, this is if if there's a couple different
issues here.
First, he needs to defeat Trump before he
gets a shot at Joe Biden.
And so I you all know, I don't get into this
whole Alpha beta way of discussing everything
by the standards of these right wingers.
It's not very alpha to go after the guy you're
not even running against in order to avoid
conflict with the guy who's actually up 30
points in the polls.
Now, we're going to talk about polling a little
bit later because since his announcement,
DeSantis is actually up 15% in the polling.
Now, let's remember, 15% and 15 percentage
points are two different things.
Before I get emails saying, David, what are
you talking about?
DeSantis is up 15% in the polls.
We'll talk about that later.
But this seems to be a bump and not a shift
in the underlying dynamics of this campaign,
which are that the majority of the Republican
Party is fine with Trump.
And those that aren't aren't looking for a
guy with the same insults and the same hand
movements who's unwilling to actually take
Trump on head on and instead is going to go
after Joe Biden.
All right.
Let's look at some more clips from this speech.
Here is DeSantis talking about the debt deal.
And, you know, one of the really interesting
things about American politics, where there
is a history of state level officials vying
for national office.
Bill Clinton was the governor of Arkansas
and then ran for president.
What Bill Clinton had that DeSantis very much
does not have is that even though Bill Clinton
was this sort of folksy Southern state governor.
When his campaign for president launched and
he was talking about foreign policy and debt
and deficit, etc., he didn't seem completely
in over in over his head.
You're going to hear Ron DeSantis talk about
debt and you will see that this state elected
official seems completely out of his element
and completely in over his head when discussing
the topics that are relevant to the national
political scene.
Speaker 2: We now see Washington is now cooked
up their latest, quote, debt deal.
And I can tell you this Our nation was careening
towards bankruptcy before the debt deal, and
it will still be careening towards bankruptcy
after this debt deal.
This is greenlighting $4 trillion in new debt
in less than two years.
It took us almost 200 years to get to 4 trillion
in debt in the first place.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, when we're talking
about the debt ceiling and the debt limit
and all of this stuff, aside from the fact
that most of these elected officials don't
even have the most basic understanding of
macroeconomics, like put that aside for a
second.
The debt limit relates to paying obligations
that have already been authorized.
It is not actually about new spending.
When these Republicans show up and say we're
new spending, new spending, new spending.
All of this spending has already been agreed
upon and it has been agreed upon by our elected
officials in the House and Senate.
You might say, well, I'm a Republican.
And when this stuff was agreed upon, we didn't
have the House or Senate.
But this is the process we have and this is
all spending that has already been authorized.
Now we're talking about meeting our existing
obligations.
Speaker 2: It locks in inflated COVID level
era levels of spending, and it keeps 98% of
the 87,000 new IRS agents that Joe Biden instituted.
This is not going to solve our nation's fiscal
problems.
Speaker 1: So, again, now we are just quite
literally the two Trump lines.
These are.
Now, I know you're trying to appeal to Republicans
and some of the stuff Trump does appeals to
Republicans.
And so you're going have to do some of the
same stuff.
But at some point, how are you going to this
is Trump's lines delivered in a really just
off putting way.
Right.
I mean, we're just it's going to be debt and
it was bankruptcy and so it's the Trump lines
delivered in a whiny your voice in Florida.
Speaker 2: We run budget surpluses we have
a $1.2 trillion GDP In Florida, we'd be the
13th largest economy in the world if we were
a separate country.
And yet, with 1.2 trillion economy, our state
debt is only $17 billion.
Speaker 1: All right.
So the crowd not super engaged, as you can
see.
And DeSantis offering nothing that we might
qualify as inspiring.
Then he went completely off the rails in delusions
of grandeur, saying he believes we can bring
George Washington back.
And this is when I mean, listen, there is
some narcissism probably required to even
think, hey, I should run for president.
Maybe people will vote for me.
But this is really too much.
Speaker 2: Bureaucracy is so entrenched that
I think we can bring George Washington back.
Can you?
And I don't think he could fix it in one single
four year term.
Speaker 1: We must.
But DeSantis can do it in two terms.
That's great news.
Speaker 2: Restore sanity to our nation.
We can't have every major institution in our
country going on ideological joyrides.
We have to be guided by reality, by facts,
and by our enduring principles.
We in the state of Florida held the line when
freedom hung in the balance.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there is nothing I am seeing here that
makes me think this is electric in a way that
it's going to put Trump out with Republican
voters.
The biggest argument that DeSantis is making
is Florida good.
I make America like Florida.
I am going to argue next that that would
be
a disaster.